[Music]
all right well this is day two of
working on
just completely restructuring ancient
archer game engine and i've been working
on the windowing system and the
callbacks and i kind of got myself into
a monkey wrench of a situation
i'm just kind of overthinking it at this
point i think and i just want to
document this experience because i'm
sure i'll get over it i've got some new
ideas of things that will probably work
but
that's not that's not the point all
right so here's
what i'm thinking and what i'm trying to
accomplish
so the core thing here is we've got
callbacks
and they take a window
to set the call back up
with
but i want to be able to instantiate
more than one window and i want it to
work properly depending on what it's
focused on which one's focused so i want
to only have
one keyboard scroll mouse input and it
to switch to controlling that window
whenever you're focused on it
so
i guess i gotta set up
the at different windows
and
this is where i kind of logically get
stuck but i found a document here
document i guess it's a forum i was
searching up how to use multiple windows
detect which it's under and it looks
like
the answer is basically you need to use
set
cursor enter callback
and basically change anything over
but
one of the things here is i'm using my
own class called window
that kind of ties everything together
and handles the multiple instantiation
stuff so
yeah i guess what i need to do here
is something like uh this guy says
and that is
for each window when i create it i need
to set its cursor and her callback
and on these callbacks i probably need
to switch over
uh which one is doing the keyboard or
scroll or mouse input
i guess that's that's where i kind of
get confused here
because basically i only wanted to take
these inputs
from the window that's currently focused
and when you switch to another one
it
still updates the the same
stuff so i could give them all a shared
point or access to it or i could just
have one okay
well that's where i'm at i'm going to
see if i can get it working all right so
and just to state for the final goal
of this i would even want to do this as
just a
epic benchmark test
open a window that does
gl4 opengl rendering open a window
that's using directx and open a window
that's using vulcan and have them all
running
fine
is that possible
i don't know someday i'll find out
but that's what i'm kind of gearing
towards it's just
smoothing this out and making it a nice
back end window that'll call the
appropriate renderer
and then we'll have our
controller
send commands and stuff
to the model and view as needed i'm
still the models not even on the radar
yet that'll be next
that's going to be
something different
all right i'm getting rambling now i'm
going to get back to coding and i'll
report back later
all right so i figured out a bit of a
solution to this whole thing you have to
set the window user pointer which was in
that form thread i
just shared
this is nothing new they're not the
first to discover it's just where i kind
of realized what it does so what this
does is it takes
uh your window pointer and sets it to
whatever class is calling it which is
going to in my case just this class
called
window plain old window
so it sets the user point of this now
what this does for us is when we now set
the callbacks
we're passing in this pointer and it's
going to have a user pointer to the
class
so in theory
i'm still getting the point where i can
actually test this for example when we
do our frame buffer size set callback
one of the things i want to do is update
the cached width and height the problem
is or was is that was stored in these
windows options so i made this a windows
options a shared pointer
that way it has its own control block
for each instantiation and then when we
hit this callback
it's going to grab
whatever window instantiated
the glfw window so this is going to
sound a little confusing because when i
just say plain window i probably mean my
window class
and i'm going to try to say glfw window
when i mean their class
because clearly i just have it as a
little piece of
potential data for the window and we
have our reasons
and the reason it's a pointer of course
is so we can
initialize it how we want
depending on these window options
all right anyway i'm getting a little
sidetracked so the point is we can use
the glfw window pointer and get the user
pointer cast it to the class it's
supposed to be
and bam there we have access to the
class
that is calling it
just by having the window so the set
user pointer is very handy thing i'm
gonna have to look into that i'm not
sure how they implement that that's cool
though
i guess it's it's probably a lot
it's just a void pointer
yeah it's just points okay that's cool
so of course you're gonna have to be a
little careful with this but it should
work fine in this case because uh
yeah just the way everything's
structured anyway
so there we go and i'm just uh
creating a new shared pointer to frame
buffer controls it's just temporary here
but that's just so we can update the
cached width and height
now
i also have this function called
find here apply changes
and that's really important because for
these windows
just flipping these options doesn't do
anything until you hit apply changes
but we can cache things that have
changed like
when the frame buffer size is the window
resizing
we want the width and heights to be
updated as well so we don't have to use
glfw calls every time we want to get
that necessarily
and they are cached right here they have
defaults
and this in theory should
adjust up to update those but we don't
want to
call apply
changes here because well the changes
have already been applied by this frame
buffer size callback and then we've
still got more stuff to do a lot more
work but that's
uh one hurdle crossed and it looks like
i'm not gonna need i was gonna
like reinstantiate this receiver
and do something with that but i don't
think we need to do that we'll just do
it like this and make it localized every
time
but in theory what we also could do is
we could go like this
and we could just like update it here
yeah like that
and then all these here
and then the thing we want to do here is
at the
end of each of these functions whenever
we're done accessing it is we want to
release it
so it would be like
window option
receiver
and then just call oh i think it's dot
release or reset yeah not reset and
that'll just kind of blank it out and
make it show so it's not pointing
anything
so
there's probably more we could do here
like we could we could check
if it's the right options already and
not have to do any of this stuff or
something like that
potentially but that's just going to get
more confusing and it's it's only it's
not even necessarily going to optimize
anything so
maybe i will leave this here right now
i like it being like this because well
you could act let's see you could access
this was act with x turn so
oh we don't actually want to do that so
we probably want to make these
static at least this one
but these other ones we're gonna
probably want to access from outside
uh
so these are gonna be like like they are
and i think the windows got an extern of
those very good and that is so
that we only have
a single set of these inputs no matter
how many windows we have
and we'll have to do some clever things
here too which i've got to research and
figure out but it shouldn't be much
longer before we have
some windows popping up and be able to
switch between them
and
put whatever context we want on each of
them why am i implementing this feature
again i don't even think my game is
going to use it i just got in my head
that i wanted to redo everything and
this is
upgrading the window to be better than
it used to be pretty much all right and
as we're digging on into it there's
maybe even a more clever and better
thing we could do
where we don't have to have this extra
shirt pointer and it doesn't even need
to be a shared pointer if it's generally
all internal well we're still going to
leave it
as a shared pointer here
because we're still going to leave this
get windows options public but what we
can do is we can make
all these callbacks friends
which means they have access to the
private members of this class so
this particular callback will be allowed
to access these window options but these
callbacks
how do they know which one
to get to and now with the user pointer
we can just grab the right instance
and say okay set it and since this
function has access to this private
options there's no need to go through a
getter and stuff
that's kind of weird for uh private
internal parts anyway
so i think that's going to be a better
solution there and we should be able to
go forward with that we won't have to
call reset and it should save us a
little bit of uh
so i just thought of something
and that is we can choose which callback
it's going to call to with this
windowing tech which should be rendering
tech
that makes a lot more sense
um
yeah so now we're going to be able to go
to these callbacks and we're also going
to be able to switch on the rendering
tech and decide which viewport update
that way
this properly we can properly support
uh the callbacks handling any of the
rendering text that we might end up
using of course right now we're only
doing opengl but at some point we will
be doing the other ones so let's go
ahead and get that in here well you just
need a case
for the rendering tech
to be
render tech
i think it's just render underscore tech
uh and then open gl4 here
uh like we want the of course
d3d
and vulcan one
and on those cases we're just gonna
break now we could throw an error i
don't know about throwing errors on a
frame buffer size callback
but uh i guess it's
we should never get here anyway this is
just boilerplate for later basically
so the next thing we want to do is
update our projection matrices i haven't
got to that yet but this should pretty
much take care of the frame buffer size
callback function until we have
a system of projection matrices we know
we want to update
so i finally got to a point where i feel
half decent about how this windowing
system is set up
overall it is pretty straightforward
there's only one way you're allowed to
initialize it and we should actually say
that the default window
is deleted
and private too why not now just public
so now the only way to create this class
is with windows off window options
and we have of course i guess i'll just
go over the whole class
for now a way to get the windows options
that way we can potentially change them
from somewhere else and then apply those
changes
if we're happy with it so we've got some
default initializations some stuff the
callbacks
here are friends so they can access
the options
and anything else they might need that
we might add later
and let's take a look at
the definitions well in here we have
some extern
to these functions because we need to
know about them they're only declared
over here
this
here is not actually a declaration
or not a proper one i don't think
i don't know i might actually play
around with this little bit you can put
x turn here in the class x turn friend
that's that's a little weird
but that means we could
remove these if it works
see no it doesn't seem to like it okay
so we're gonna have to have it here
we're going to keep it the the way it
was
this is just something i'm kind of
playing around with a little bit it
seems to work okay with
the way it was
or it's a friend here
next turn up here alright so there's the
initializer it just sets the windows
options to whatever we provided and then
calls default to knit now default init
it's basically going to read all our
options and try to set up things and
currently we're only doing opengl so it
just launches an opengl window
tries to get 4.6 if possible
and makes the context current procs the
address
i didn't want any opengl calls in here
so that's why
uh this is moved
over like so but that's
uh comes with its own
i don't want to say issues
but
i don't know i'd like to do this some
other way i'm trying to think of a
better way i guess i'll readdress that
when rendering becomes more of a thing
set the user pointer to this class
that way we can get it in the callbacks
and then we set the callbacks
and there's only two right now but
obviously we'll have more later
and basically well the error one we set
earlier
the frame buffer size set callbacks when
the window size changes we already went
over that one
and we got a mouse reporting which i'm
still working on because basically we
want to update the mouse input receiver
but we've got to have it set first
and it's going to be shared across all
the windows
but
well the idea is only the window that's
active is actually going to use
whatever's coming in
but it could in theory get the input
from any window i don't know if that's
the best idea or if i should make a new
one of these for each
i'm still thinking about that a little
bit
but that's pretty much how it's going to
go
and
what we're working on now
is just a front-end interface of this
where you can initialize a new instance
and each call to this is going to open a
new window with the options provided so
you could essentially keep opening
windows
with different options so
like we were saying earlier we want to
get one of each renderer up just as a
epic benchmark
but that's basically where i left off
now
so i'm trying to come up with a nice
core structure for the front end
uh and i think i'm going to basically
make a class of instances
might as well store them in a vector
and we're going to carefully manage this
vector of instances
i think that'll work i'm still working
this one out
[Music]
you